imminent flooding across the southeast
texas coast into louisiana incredible
unprecedented and historic amounts of
rain houston texas devastated by
hurricane harvey but now hollywood's
biggest stars are coming together to
help i love you houston it is of course
beyonce's hometown and the superstar has
turned the efforts of her be good
charity toward the city it's our
opportunity to come together as one to
help out all the great families in
distress down in houston jlo and a-rod
joined forces announcing a 50 000
donation and encouraged others to give
what they can meanwhile kevin hart
launched a celebrity fundraising
campaign i'm challenging a lot of my
celebrity friends to follow my lead and
donating 25 000
to hurricane harvey to the red cross
okay dwayne the rock johnson was one of
the stars who took kevin up on his
challenge i want to send a message to
the people of houston you got to stay
strong and you got to hold on to faith
as was dj khaled sending our love and
our prayers then there's country star
chris young whose house was actually
damaged in the storm he pledged a
hundred thousand dollars toward relief i
love you guys and every little bit helps
more stars are helping in other ways
bachelor alum sean lowe headed down from
dallas with his boat to help with rescue
missions while fixer uppers chip and
joanna gaines are donating all proceeds
of their texas forever merchandise to
disaster relief and coldplay debuted a
new song in honor of the
[Music]
no
city
in that city where they send you
into space
[Music]
i'm dreaming of when i get back to texas